your journey to self-realization will be
unique to you and you alone
embark on a journey to fall in love with
yourself remember that there is nothing
more powerful than an embodied human
being that knows itself
find out what is your way of being in
the world what is it that you love what
is it that makes you feel connected what
is valuable to you what do you enjoy do
that because that's going to bless
everyone around you and you you first
hey everybody Welcome to the podcast for
those of you spiritually inclined I've
got good news because the wise the holy
the Ethereal Julie piatt AKA srimati my
in-house spiritual Guru my better half a
wise force of nature who is just so good
at so many things I'm never not inspired
to do and be better myself is here today
for those new or unfamiliar Julie is an
accomplished Yogi she's a musician a
chef a mom to our four children she's
also the best-selling author of three
vegan cookbooks she hosts the for the
life of me podcast and Lord's over water
tiger her online spiritual Community
she's also the CEO and mother Arc of
srimu absolutely the best plant-based
cheese in the known universe I'm not
biased which if you have yet to try I
highly recommend you do so and you can
do that by by going to sreemude.com
srinu.com and if you use the promo code
rrp20 you'll get free shipping on orders
over 127 long time listeners are well
acquainted with Julie she's been a
recurring source of spiritual wisdom on
the podcast dropping many a pearl over
the years on basically everything
everything from parenting and creativity
to finding meaning purpose finding
direction grappling with love grief and
everything in between today's
conversation centers on the ways we can
all become more embodied more connected
to the core of our true beings we
discuss how to find direction in our
intuition we talk about how to remove
obstacles on your path to self-growth
how to face trauma and how to cultivate
self-love every podcast with Julie is
sure to deliver some soul nourishing
magic this conversation is no exception
so uh
turn a tarot card or two spin the
medicine wheel and open ourselves the
wisdom of Julie Pyatt
[Music]
well the high priestess is back
I think only Gaia knows what's to come
and uh I don't know what are we gonna do
we're gonna just see what comes out the
other side the open to the Divine
unfoldment let's do that I mean are we
courageous enough to just sit in the
emptiness
and allow
whatever is there to arise makes me very
nervous I know we have done the least
planning we we didn't even have our
conversation about not planning this
time I almost brought it up yeah like
this is the Trope we start every podcast
by talking about uh my pattern of coming
to you and saying we need to talk about
what we're going to talk about and you
rebuffing me but after 10 years of that
I now know that that's a fruitless
Endeavor so I did kind of say are we
gonna
you want to go over anything but
actually say it's a fruitful Endeavor
because the because the podcast between
you and me have delivered some magic
every time there is a trip there is some
I mean obviously you would not invite me
back if that was not the case
they are like being married to you no
but even so that you wouldn't have no
they deliver I think that speaks to uh
perhaps my Brilliance well your
Brilliance but also and your Brilliance
and my insecurity or imposter syndrome
because after 10 years of doing this
I by and large over prepare every time I
like to be prepared and then afterwards
out I think maybe I shouldn't have
prepared that much
maybe I should trust my self at this
point that I know how to get through a
two-hour conversation and make it you
know somewhat make it work
um
that's my process I think it's because
sorry to interrupt you on your own show
but uh I think it's because of the
juxtaposition of our processes and the
way that we both do things in a
different way and how we somehow allow
the space for those two things to exist
in the same space in Love Somehow they
both can be true
so thank you for that yeah well thank
you for your spontaneity and your your
your very different approach that
despite the discomfort that it presents
I do trust and know that that it will
all work out now hopefully it will
because now we've said this whole thing
and now what if it doesn't what if it
like what if it's not really fruitful
the ball is in your court it deposit my
court oh my god well hi ritual what has
you lit up right now what are your yeah
so I think it's thinking about yeah
thanks I mean I think it's a really
profound time on planet Earth I mean
obviously we've been talking about that
for a bit
um but I am really feeling a quickening
in the energies of creation of newness
of a new birth of a new uh Awakening a
new operating system in many many areas
of human life
um that is coupled with uh some
absolutely unimaginable
uh scenarios of suffering of death of
exit
um what comes to mind in what has been
on my heart uh just recently is the
devastating earthquake in Syria and
turkey
and so you know these things are
profound uh Beyond Comprehension
um the level of suffering the immensity
of that planetary Earth adjustment
um uh you know it's it's beyond it's
it's beyond imagination that anyone
would ever suffer
you know such an experience and uh
seeing some of the um videos of children
being trapped
for weeks uh you know alone babies
children uh you know men women moms uh
you know fathers Brothers uncles uh and
to to see the heroicism of humanity uh
coming to get them coming to dig them
out
um you know it's had me on my knees you
know quite frankly uh of recent and
you know my prayer is always for us in
those scenarios that you know let the
suffering be the least possible like the
least possible moment and allow
something else that unseen that Divine
that that Grace to surround our beloved
Humanity our brothers our sisters our
children uh and and may uh maybe they be
guided and carried you know into the
next realm with peace and comfort and
beauty and care and nourishment and
celebration
um so you know that is happening you
know on on this planet and at the same
time uh I have not felt this level of
creativity of joy of expansion of
connection uh people
um both old friends and new friends
coming into you know the field into life
experiences and there is a quickening
you can feel something is at hand and
something very miraculous and very
beautiful well that's beautifully put
um I do feel
kinship with the notion that that it is
a moment or an era of extremes
Everything feels very extreme
um from the tragic end of the spectrum
to the rebirth end you talked about new
operating systems and new models for
Humanity and you know over the past two
weeks or so as you know like Adam and I
have been working on this episode around
artificial intelligence kind of a
documentary style
Twist on our normal format that we're
really excited about but we've been
having lots of conversations with people
who are on the front lines of this
emergent operating system so in the
birth of you know new uh modalities for
you know human operating systems we're
seeing the birth of new operating
systems in the artificial realm as well
that are already having massive impacts
on
how we think about our own humanity and
how we kind of function in the workplace
and Beyond and it's been revelatory but
also something that has given me pause
like I think we're on the cusp of of
of
you know truly a paradigm shift
in not just technology but how we
reflect upon you know who we are as
human beings and what we have to offer
in the face of such a powerful
technology that that at this point is
becoming more and more perfect at
mimicking human behavior which is
confusing and creates a sort of uh
uncanny valley that uh is freaky you
know and I think this is just the
beginning of all of that and it's
unclear what's going to happen but it's
hard not to entertain dystopic thoughts
about you know the implications of
something so powerful that's being
Unleashed Upon Us essentially without
consent uh
and all of the you know impossible to
foresee uh implications of that well
that's a very healthy
um awareness and concern that you have
um and that is uh an agenda that is
rolling out on planet Earth it is part
of our Evolution part of what we signed
up to sort of uh experience and and make
choices and and co-create with or not
and you know as a as a spiritual being
as one who is connecting to uh the true
organic life print the original
instruction sets of what makes up a
Divine human being
my response is that we have the choice
to choose our organic embodiment our
original organic intention and you said
something very powerful that AI mimics
Humanity it is not Humanity it can never
be humanity and there is a sense it's a
I'll call it a spidey sense or the
Supreme intelligence which exists within
the heart so the heart is the true
Supreme intelligence that we have it is
not the mind and so the mechanism that
tells you the difference between AI what
is false what is non-human and what is
human is a feeling tone it's a feeling
sensation and so we're getting trained
to understand how to scan situations
people experiences
food music all kinds of things and
determine is that an organic life form
or is that inorganic
but as these Technologies mature and
become more sophisticated infinitely
more sophisticated than they currently
are that ability that Attunement to
organic versus inorganic will become
more difficult to decipher
and you know there would there I'm sure
there are people who would say why does
that distinction matter ultimately well
it matters deeply unless you want to be
um artificial
so I would just say that
um again reminding ourselves that there
is nothing more powerful than an
embodied human being that knows itself
remember that nothing has the ability to
be in your energetic field your body
your life stream without your consent
and so there are universal laws that you
can activate by claiming your Sovereign
embodiment in your own life form and so
you're gonna you'll have a choice and
there'll be um you know a million
different levels that you can hybridize
or not uh but uh it is a choice and with
Attunement with awareness
you can learn to discern what is false
and I would say even more than that
Humanity has an innate innate ability to
recognize something that's not right
they can go um yeah that just doesn't
feel right that seems off that seems
artificial so I I think we do have a
very strong mechanism with which to
discern and so in your uh uh in in
casting your spiritual gaze forward what
is the near and long-term future look
like for
this particular landscape well I mean I
can't predict the future and you know
the future is being made in the moments
it's all happening in the present moment
um but I do know that this is a
planetary procession unlike any other
time it is not like any time in history
previous
we are literally the uh the show of the
Multiverse many eyes are upon us and
this is a wonderful wonderful realm to
be incarnated in to to experience life
for evolution I can't tell you I can't
predict the future all I can tell you is
that choosing
Sovereign embodiment in your own body
in all things is a great awareness and a
great power so for somebody who's
listening to this or watching it uh
who's new to perhaps the types of
Concepts that that uh you are immersed
in what would that mean like if
somebody's like well maybe I'd like to
make that choice but I don't even know
what she is yeah I mean it starts well
it starts in the beginning you know it
starts with self-inquiry with Yoga
practices and I I don't mean Yoga
practices to then go put yourself in a
lineage that then is a box that then
confines you but uh to start to explore
the truth that every single life form uh
it comes from the one breath and that
each of us are sacred in our own
inherent design and so what it is is
it's more of a removing blocks mental
setups attitudes judgments
um maybe the way you were raised this
may be lies you were told and starting
to really embark on a journey to fall in
love with yourself and this is of course
what I teach in my water tiger
mentorship all the techniques are
designed to lead you into fully
embodiment of who you are the most
important perspective in your life is
yours and yours alone
your journey to self-realization will be
unique to you and you alone this is very
hard for Humanity at large to grasp
because the mind is always looking for a
consensus it wants to know the answer it
wants to know what's the best diet
what's going to happen what's the best
technology what's the best training
practice it wants to create these boxes
of some truth because it makes the ego
or the personality feel more comfortable
more safe but the truth of the matter is
we are billions of unique life forms
living in this realm and the experience
of life is unique for each of us so it's
about taking responsibility
understanding no one is coming there's
no one coming that's going to save you
that's going to resolve your issues your
challenges experiences desires dreams
the things that you took a body to
experience and so we have this wonderful
blessing of life and that is to discover
who we are to express ourselves and for
me those Treasures have been and will
always be residing in the heart this is
a journey that that that uh
you know I'd like to think that I'm on
and the more uh deeply I I immerse
myself into uh
into this process the more I realize how
much work remains like I feel like I've
done a lot of work and each step along
the way I realize
um not only is there no Finish Line but
perhaps that Finish Line gets a little
bit more distant you know I mean this is
like this is the practice right like and
I've done certain things over the past
year that have been revelatory and
healing and
um
and and really helped me make peace with
uh my past and allowed me to enter into
a deeper level of forgiveness and
compassion
um
but the thing that is ultimately resting
beneath all of it that has remained a
struggle is the self-love piece like I
am
for reasons I somewhat understand and
also don't understand
uh have such difficulty with
self-forgiveness or
um granting myself the level of
forgiveness and compassion that I would
um
that I would you know Grant even a
stranger with ease
[Music]
would you like a free code to water
tiger yeah I might I might have to join
your experience maybe I mean I don't
know maybe but maybe not maybe I'm not
your healer yeah no so you know when I
went so the audience knows like I I in
uh prior to Christmas I was up in
Portland at Dr Paul Conti's clinic and
did a week-long you know pretty intense
um Deep dive into family of origin stuff
healing past trauma and you know a lot
of it
um I came away from that you know with a
with a greater understanding of my kind
of blueprint and the things that kind of
motivated my behaviors and led me to
become
the person that I am
um but again like there is that layer of
like can you just love yourself
unconditionally well I mean you can't
resolve something in a week you know
like obviously it was a starting point
yeah it's a start it's a very beginning
point and the other thing is is that
this goes on forever like it never will
that's my point yeah so it doesn't
matter what you know it's funny I not
that funny but I recently heard somebody
raving about oh you know there's this
enlightened being and he's made it
through the 12 stages of Enlightenment
you know and I just sort of smiled I
mean you know I'm sure the the being is
very amazing and very beautiful but it's
all a system it's all a perspective it's
just a fractal it's a perspective of the
crystal of which we all make up we we
all come from that and so the other
thing that I would like to just offer
you as your beloved and as someone who
uh cares for you deeply and and I know
that we we share this so you say this
self-love part is so tough for you well
it's tough for all of us I mean that is
the thing I mean you can talk to Giselle
who's like the most beautiful supermodel
ever and she'll tell you that she felt
ugly judged I mean I don't know her so
Giselle I don't know if they really said
that but I'm just I'm gonna I'm gonna
wager that that's true it doesn't matter
it's like it's part of the human
condition because we leave the one and
we come into a body and we feel this
immense separation and with that
separation comes this you know falling
from from the unity basically so it's by
design that it happens that way
but what I would offer to you is that
I'm starting to think that it's not
going to be hard at all actually I've
had a couple experiences in the last few
months where I've I've glanced aspects
of being embodied in let's say a more
High vibrating life form like in my body
and and so you know as we're you know
we're you know I'm doing Pilates or you
know I'm taking care of my skin or I'm
making sure that I hike and that I
meditate and that you know I don't carry
stress in my body
um you know I think you know I'm feeling
like you know I I want to take care of
my physical form and I had this moment
where this sort of quantum uh
presence came into my body and showed me
just a glimpse of the power the
Perfection the beauty that is just there
Beyond this density and then I started
laughing and I said actually I don't
maybe it's not going to be hard at all
maybe when the frequency gets to that
point it's going to be like the wind
blows across your cheek and suddenly
you're rejuvenated you know your back is
feeling better like we're you know so
again it's like this idea of hard work
is old
in a lot of ways old Paradigm it
shouldn't be hard work I am not
disciplined I am not working hard at
spirituality I am in a state of
beingness of connection to the breath
the moment the presence the allowing the
surrender and The Greatest Secret that I
can share on your show today and right
now in my life the super power is
relaxation
that is the superpower
so everyone listening to this just
consider how you are when you're working
so hard you're going for things so you
know committed you're you're wanting
this so badly it's like just observe all
the things in your body that are
constricting
it's closing off your life force it's
cut it's causing a closing down of
energy and what if you knew that the
more you could relax just everybody just
let your belly go
let your body just relax start to
connect to your breath and what if you
knew that the more you relaxed the more
light could enter you the more help you
can get from the universe the more you
merge with that which is really
sourcing you living you breathing you
so this whole idea of this work you know
we got to work and it's got to be so
hard doesn't it's actually not true it's
an illusion so again many years ago
when your beloved friend who was on the
cover of Time Magazine The Olympian the
swimmer he's a reverend
um Byron Davis yeah Byron Davis he was
sitting at her kitchen table and you
guys were having this conversation we
were having this conversation and I was
like how about training for the love of
it like Just For the Love of it and he
told this story he was training for
qualifying round or something and he
woke up with the flu and he was not in
his best self and he was swimming and
he's and he was getting beat and then
suddenly he said something Beyond
himself came in and he entered this
relaxation and he won
and we had that conversation back then
so it's not it's not foreign to you I
know that but I'm reminding you
and I'm not saying so then don't say
that oh well then how does anything get
done you know I do 29 things all the
time
it's it's the way it's done it's the
intention that it's done in
and so this world is a beautiful world
where we get to evolve through
experiences and that's why every single
one of your desires you should
experience it you should do it you
should go for it Go in it feel it you
know be it become it because that's
Evolution and that's what we're here for
yeah it's a really powerful concept that
is deeply uh
paradoxical for me or counter-intuitive
in that I'm so wired around the
Protestant work ethic mentality in the
way that I was raised and then the
evidence that my mind points to which is
constantly reaffirming this notion that
if you want something or you want to
achieve something or you have a goal
that you're chasing whatever it is that
success in that regard is a direct
directly correlates the amount of work
you're willing to put in and in my case
that is you know inextricably connected
to suffering right so if if I'm going to
write a book if I'm gonna whatever I'm
gonna do like it will only be as good as
I am willing to suffer for it which is a
lie that I've told myself time and time
again and I've been able through
self-will to achieve certain things
with that disposition But ultimately it
is an unsustainable energy source so the
idea that you are going to release that
pattern that entrenched neural pathway
that is constantly telling you that that
is the way to do things and instead be
in a place of receiving presence
acceptance and ease is so uncomfortable
like I would rather just grind and sweat
and like you know have sleepless nights
and then just be like what if it was
easy what if you could just allow it to
happen and it would happen
because in my brain my brain then says
well that doesn't make sense how is that
going to work that feels like a risk
so it's it's extremely uncomfortable and
yet
clearly there is you know profound
wisdom in that right like if you could
just
adopt a mindset of abundance do the work
but not attach the suffering and the
toil and the pain to the work
have a healthy distance from the uh from
expectations and from the results of
your efforts
and be in a in this place of like
allowing and I'll tell you what your key
is
the key
is devotion
it's understanding
that you are not responsible for
anything that has occurred in your life
that it is not because of your hard work
it is not because you're so smart or
you're smarter than someone else or you
you know did X Y and Z it's by the grace
of the force that's why your body is
doing millions of operations that your
mind could never ever Define happening
right now in the body
and
it's the devotional part that frees you
if you understand that it's not you but
it's the breath working through you
then you can't one can become devotional
to that life force and serve that life
force yes very specifically through you
it's not going to be different through
you than it is through me but it's
really just the one and you use the word
work but actually in this example of
this extraordinary podcast that you have
been placed in the middle of
without having it on your bucket list or
your vision board or
you literally did it because you loved
it
and really Divine mother or the force or
Consciousness we'll call it the breath
knows your heart's desires better than
you know them yourself
and after you went through a fair amount
of
I would say initiations tests alchemical
experiences it placed you in a field
doing something that you love more than
anything
you are perfectly designed to do this
type of podcast interview sharing
information conversation and what I
would say to you is that the core of the
conversations is not work for you it is
pure joy for you
and so the opportunity is to maybe
change some of your language around the
word work what if you change the word to
Discovery
the discovery the journey the creation
the exploration you know it's not like
shreemu gets launched because I just sat
around and was like you know the breath
will take care of it it's because the
body acts all the time because I'm
receiving impulses and messages and
guidance and people are being brought to
me it's creating a magnetism my devotion
my connection my alignment with it the
values the way that I created creates a
magnetism that then brings me all these
opportunities and then I get to decide
you know is that is that a you know is
that that much an alignment that I'm
going to go deeper or am I going to just
bless it and let it go
but I'm never in the illusion that I did
this because I worked so hard and I
deserve it and it just it's just
breathing through me it's like wow you
know so
um and you know and I and and I I love
it you know I love the desires that are
in my my heart and there are many things
that you know I'm still doing and and
want to do and and uh and I love it I
love the creation process I love the
process I love all the other artistic
collaborators all the people that I get
to meet with during the process but
you're in this position because you went
through a devotional Alchemy in our
nine-year alchemical experience and she
presented you uh Your Perfect Design of
what you were designed to do
perfectly
I feel like I have a good uh
appreciation for that like I don't think
of this as a result of me and my ego
like I I I I I do Embrace that concept
um and it's freeing the more that you
can like live in that space
uh because you don't feel the weight on
your shoulders as much right like I
didn't do this this is happening for a
reason that is beyond my
the limitations of you know the the
intellect and yet I still struggle so
deeply to disconnect from my
identification with the mind right and
meditation is helpful and mindfulness
practices understanding the nature of
mind like non-dual meditation practice
like trying to get a glimpse of the
vastness of Consciousness and the
mysteries of that like the more I go
deeper into that
the easier it is to relinquish self-will
and to uh you know recognize
the perniciousness of the ego or when
the ego is flaring up and trying to like
seize that kind of control but
it's it's a it's a game of inches for me
you know but there is you said earlier
like that idea that it doesn't have to
be hard like whatever kind of Greater
truce that you're trying to
be in connection with in relationship
with
clearly that is not the result of effort
like if you're just to use the
meditation example it's like if you're
gripping your hands like I'm gonna
meditate so hard and I'm gonna
understand what this is all about is
obviously contrary to the nature of that
practice
because the glimpses of
of of
the reality of Consciousness and and the
true nature of the Mind only comes from
the letting go of all of that and in the
allowing and it's not necessarily
something that would only come after
years of practice you could have that
realization instantaneously in a moment
yeah that's true it's true I feel like
most people want to eat better they want
to improve their diets absolutely have
you heard of it I've heard of it this
trips up so many people we thought hey
we know a couple things about how to do
this a few so we created this thing
called the plant power meal planner that
is this beautiful offering whereby you
gain access to literally thousands of
plant-based recipes that you can totally
customize based upon your preferences
your allergies your peccadillos it
integrates with grocery delivery so all
the ingredients that you need get
shipped right to your door so you can
make this stuff that you've pre-selected
and we all could use a little
inspiration and support when preparing
meals for our families in our busy lives
so we hope you join us no matter what
your eating style is we have our arms
open wide and we've saved you a space at
our family table to join us in eating
more healthy vibrant plant-based meals
visit meals Dot richroll.com
[Laughter]
one secret that I want to share with you
is that
your ability to connect with people is
directly related to the
experience that you have allowed your
health yourself to have where you have
faced your trauma
and when you went to that experience and
you came back I felt an intimacy with
you that I have not felt in our entire
relationship
so that trauma tell me more my eco wants
to know more no but I mean that trauma
that you're holding that you think isn't
anything
is keeping you from Love
it's keeping you from Love
and you know self-love is the first
thing of course I mean but you know we
hear it very you know like if you can't
love yourself you can't love another but
I mean like really like it's really
really true but I mean love yourself
literally like like I am I am a creation
of the Divine and I came in in this
manner and these are the things that I'm
designed to do
and this is something that is in my
heart something that feels resonant to
me and this is the thing that I do
uniquely you really do it uniquely and
then after you go through that
experience you get to a place where you
you you're so fulfilled that then it
starts to expand and touch the all and I
would say even in those unique
experiences it does touch the all I mean
you're touching lots of people in this
show and and um you know and that's
deeply impactful you know all of us that
are sharing our stories all of us
through podcasts and books and songs and
paintings and whatever we're doing I
mean it touches our Humanity but that is
really the key it's like
um the the level that you are separate
from yourself
is what is keeping you from further
connection and so to your mind looking
at me what are the things that are still
separating me from myself or acting as
barriers to breakthroughs greater
epiphanies freedom and the ability to
step into uh you know I'm more liberated
way of being well all those things we
just sort of cover them so attachment to
the mind is intellect as being Superior
attachment to science as being Superior
um you know attachment to having to
suffer and bleed and it making the
experience valid
um could be a an experience could be
very valid it could be life-changing but
it shouldn't be exclusive to something
like an experience that comes like a
breath like a kiss on the cheek is
equally as valuable as
The Experience where you bled out on the
pavement
so um I would say probably that and I
would say also just
um the hiding from the trauma you know
the the the not wanting to go in and
really look at
um life experience so that you can look
at it you can bless it you can transmute
it you can move Beyond it you know
there's forgiveness of of everyone of
self of other people and you know we're
all going through it at some level you
know this is the condition of this realm
you know you incarnate you separate you
choose the other experience and one
thing that's really really up for me
right now
is that every single thing is connected
there isn't any event that happens in
your life in my life in anyone's life
today
that is not connected it's like I used
to you know of course there's more signs
you know that come in different ways but
it's like now it's just becoming
completely normal like of course it's
all related
um the way the patterns are setting up
it's unbelievable how connected
everything is
and furthermore with that is it's a
practice of
really understanding and seeing everyone
as divine
like it's this you know Equanimity you
know there is no value difference in
creation the sun is shining on all
creation without a degree without a
scientific study
without a social class you know color
sex gender choice of life it literally
does not care it doesn't even care if
you're spiritual or not you know
spirituality is a choice of experience
right someone could just live out in the
mountains or be an animal Whisperer or a
dog lover or you know a gardener and
they they would be as loved as would the
criminal the murderer the homeless
it's a whole Spectrum experience and
it's not for us to judge
what is you know what is what is divine
or not Divine but it is for us to use
discernment so it does matter who you
spend your time with so that's just a
very happy about the distinction between
judgment and discernment oh yeah that's
that's a good one so so if you just feel
into judgment feel into the vibration of
that word you'll find a separation a
barrier of this or that that is wrong
that does not ex that does not have the
right to exist or that is bad there is a
bad person and a good person so that
carries that type of information
but discernment is a much more refined
it's a much more high level
so it's like hmm that is that being's
choice of life experience and then
you're like is that alignment in
alignment with my my inner child that I
have to protect that it's my job to
protect or my soul or my choice
but just because I choose
um to align with the date on this plate
in front of us
does not mean that the chocolate bar is
evil
it's just a choice
that's all it is it's a choice
and in another Incarnation I might be
the chocolate bar
so remembering that as we as we're
living simultaneous lifetimes in
uh
different space times
as a soul evolving our journey is to
evolve and then eventually at some point
return home
so we're experiencing lots of different
fractals flavors identities of life
experience
and so it's like that saying you know uh
you know you you shouldn't throw stones
if you live in a glass house or I don't
know if that really works with this one
but you know the idea of like you know
somebody said to me when when I had to
file bankruptcy during our journey our
sacred Journey
they were like well you know uh if I
were you I just wouldn't choose
bankruptcy I just wouldn't choose it and
I said to them oh really I said it might
just choose you someday
so it's not
you know we should really
be reverent to life
because
this human life is quite profound and
quite
challenging
and uh there's no place for us to be
judging others
um
is there ever a place
in which it's appropriate to judge
another no only discernment only
discernment I am not I am not the one in
this form
so I will remain in reverence
and I will cultivate life-affirming
energy as much as I can
I commit to clearing out any trauma or
residue in my energetic field Body Mind
spirit
and um
I serve with devotion and I will take
responsibility for alignment and also
always discern
always because we are sovereign
embodied humans that have great power
when we remember who we are
but that sovereignty on some level yes
ultimate ultimately we're Sovereign
beings and yet
so many of the actions that we repeat or
the ideas that we have or the opinions
uh that we hold or the decisions that we
make
are being impulsed by
things that are disconnected from
one sovereignty and in saying that what
I'm thinking about is this
uh intergenerational piece right this is
top of mind because of the work that
I've done but the deeper I go into this
world
the more clearly I'm able to see how
much of not only my behavior the the
patterns that I that recur in my life
are the result of of you know how it was
brought up or you know things that
happen to me Etc and this is of course
the case for everybody right and so
there's a there's a attention or a
disconnect between that sovereignty that
we're seeking to embody and the
autopilot nature with which you know we
live our lives for the most part
unconscious of like you were saying
earlier you know the courage to go to
like
you know look at that trauma that you
didn't want to look at like you know I I
would have told you some years ago like
there's nothing to see you know like
it's not like oh I'm I'm pushing this
thing down and like don't bring it up
because that's too painful to deal with
I would have been like I'm good like I
don't know that there there's no there
there right but I think there is a there
there for everybody
and again without judgment it's not
about people being bad or good or
anything like that but the more
awareness that I develop around
this inner connectivity between you know
that goes back generations and
generations and generations and how
these uh you know certain aspects of
personality
show up time and time again is quite
revelatory it's empowering ultimately
when you can see that and then of course
the harder work is like how do you
untangle those knots and and create new
healthier patterns to arrest the the
kind of Gestalt of these patterns onto
the Next Generation like we're all here
to do better than our parents to live a
little bit more enlightened than those
who came before us and to really see
unhealthy patterns and then shoulder the
responsibility to somehow arrest them so
that you're not only perpetrating them
yourself but also as a parent passing
them on to the next generation
is there any
more worthy work to do right like that
is a it's been like extraordinary for me
that's super cool to hear you say that
it's beautiful
so just a couple things
um
so many of us incarnated at this point
at this time this point of planetary
procession because the energetics are at
a place that they have never been in you
know eons of time let's say I'm not even
going to say a number because I'm not
good with numbers but
um
so
when you free yourself of those patterns
you will free not only yourself and not
only your children but all of your
ancestry back and forward through time
how does that work consider that
it's an energetic that will literally
clear it throughout the family lines
that is a lot of what the private
session work that I do we're clearing
ancestral trauma so we're all alive on
planet Earth and we have been in a
forced reincarnation cycle so we're
we're taking bodies and then we have
alcoholism and then we drop the body and
then we come back and then it's done
again and it's passed on to our kids and
you're just you know you see these
patterns repeated right through through
the family line I mean it's just
happening so we can just take a moment
and just understand that this has all
been by Design and so I'm going to get
like sci-fi on you now but from my
perspective uh this is being
um orchestrated from off planet and so
it's not the politics it's not the
churches it's not I mean it is but I
mean it's a it's a it's a play it's a
movie like it depends on what Fishbowl
you're in like are you looking at it
from this level are you looking at it
from another level are you looking at it
from an expanded level
so by Design
this planet has been preyed upon we'll
just say by anti-life
forms for our resources for our energy
for our Consciousness and we are in a
war over Consciousness right now with AI
this is this is the realm that we are in
and so the difference is that this is a
planetary procession moment where for
the first time in many many thousands of
years the lines of incarnation of life
form into this planetary realm are free
or I would say they are occupied by life
affirming forces
and so you know this is something that
has been spoken of in many of the
ancient lineages
it is just not uh some repetition of of
History you know you can look in the
yugas you can look in the Mayan calendar
um that's not really my specialty
I teach through life experience and
through knowing what is true in my body
and so it's not because we're such low
lives so we just can't get it together
or that other person is so dumb or you
know this race of people just didn't get
it it's because it's been by Design and
we've been controlled in many many areas
of our life much more than we are aware
of and you know we had that movie come
out like during the pandemic was it
called social social dilemma yeah social
dilemma so it's like you know many many
things have been being impulsed into the
planetary field as well as mind control
it they'll you know they can impulse
energies around the field that can
create certain things
so um now is a time where you can claim
your sovereignty you know and I can see
this making you very uncomfortable on
your show but you brought it up so I
mean I never go into these Realms but I
mean this is the truth you know this is
what is happening and I mean you want
proof look around why continuously do we
let our humanities starve when we have
enough money to feed them why
continuously are these patterns of War
they just go around in cycles and Cycles
why is there no resolution in the
political system and you know as long as
I've been alive they've been you know
gun control like all these things that
happen and it just is a cycle that
repeats and repeats and repeats I have
to believe that if you were holding one
or two or three or four percent of the
wealth of the planet you would do
something with that money I'm gonna just
wager that you would and help our
Humanity but repeatedly we are not
and so for me
you know it's not like I've seen an
alien recently but uh I just look at the
evidence so am I seeing my Humanity
freed I'm not and going back to Yogi
teachings and lineages one moment of
realization is more valuable than ten
thousand lifetimes of Charity because
when you wake up it reverberates
throughout all creation
so you said what is more worthy than
clearing your ancestral trauma
yeah what is more worthy than waking up
waking up to the fact that you are a
Divine emanation of the Sacred one that
breathed you into life you are
omniscient you are eternal and you are
Divine and that is every single one of
us listening to this podcast and Beyond
people also that aren't listening to
this podcast but again it's a choice and
there are different timelines and we're
not all like going up in the air in a
fifth dimensional balloon you know it's
not like up up and away that's not going
to happen you know look around you
probably probably would not be a good
idea to go up on a balloon right now
probably not we're shooting down
Ballance yeah but go ahead yeah so you
know it's it's not everyone not everyone
is in the same operating system not
everyone has chosen the same life path
and it's okay
um but you do have a choice you have a
choice to claim your Sovereign
embodiment and to at least at the end of
the day when you put your head on that
pillow let it be your life that you
lived
and and find out what is your way of
being in the world what is it that you
love
what is it that makes you feel connected
what is valuable to you what do you
enjoy do that because that's going to
bless everyone around you and you you
first is that super scary that whole
thing that's good I think it's a good
place to take a quick break okay and
we'll come back we get to break now yeah
take a break okay
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with them
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
that was really beautiful what you just
said and as you were recounting that I
was thinking about maybe this is weird
but I was thinking about
uh that dinner that we had a couple
weeks ago where we were invited to uh
Mike posner's house and it was like Mike
Posner and Doug Evans like making a
sprout dinner and Doug's wife Siobhan in
queue was there
um
and uh
and uh and just watching
Mike Posner who is so naturally
um
full of like joy and awe and wonder and
ease about himself like he's just
naturally brimming with like enthusiasm
and and a sort of beautiful childlike
you know nature to his to his like
Sovereign self
uh and I was imagining like I don't
think that he's like grinding his teeth
when he's writing music like it's coming
from a place of joy and devotion and
reverence just the way about him right
and as we're eating dinner I'm watching
him and I'm like wow what would it be
like to be like that because I'm you
know acrosity cynical guy who's
self-conscious and up in my head and you
know not feeling connected to my body in
in that way and the distance between
kind of how he gracefully walks the
planet and the way that I do are so
different like there and I was like
there's a lot to be learned by how he is
you know and I was wondering
has he always been that way did he
undergo some kind of process to become
like that or more like that but I've
been thinking about that a lot right
which speaks to what you're talking
about which is
releasing self-will and and being in
this place of presence and and devotion
and and you know really you know
telescoping up ten thousand feet to
realize like we're
temporarily on this spinning Rock and we
have just a moment to
to you know express our ourselves and to
share love and joy that's amazing maybe
he can come over and spoon with you
intense I'm sure he'd be up for it but
it was like in queue was there it was
like in queue Doug
Joanna yeah
um and Mike and another guy I didn't
know right now and it's like wow there's
a lot of podcast episodes sitting around
that's right she's sitting here exactly
exactly and uh and and Mike if if Doug
is the Sprout King uh Mike Posner is the
prince of sprouting I think he's the
heir apparents he is he's a very
enthusiastic they are very beautiful
very beautiful people anyway it's
amazing well uh in the middle of the
table we have this beautiful cheese
board do you want to do like a cheese
board presentation for every podcast
that we do so we just have this for
every episode for everyone well it is
really cool a door in the table with but
you know what it's it's srimu is such a
an amazing
um food offering
um I just came from visiting my friends
uh Gabby and Rodrigo up in Marin County
and they have recently
um invested in srimu and they have
welcomed me into their community and uh
I went up to their home where they
hosted first a tea ceremony
uh which we made this incredible cheese
board and it just goes along beautifully
you know at like 5 p.m like sort of at
that time
and then the following night they had a
party of of some just very amazing
um I would say conscious entrepreneurs
that are changing the face of humanity
and um and we served you know cheese
boards and and it was just the perfect
food it was like enough substance
sustenance
um delicious flavor paired with kombucha
or organic wine and many different
eating types you know plant-based keto
paleo gluten-free dairy free there was a
woman there who was just thanking me
literally told me srimu changed her life
because she's not been able to eat dairy
for you know 10 years or something so
um you know these cheese boards just
keep on delivering and we have Easter
coming up Passover spring time
um and srimu is just such an amazing
offering to bring to any Gathering any
dinner party and you know here I did
this board you know very sort of a
little bit more sparse but again just
using your creativity and getting a
bouquet of flowers and fresh berries and
your favorite chocolates and making sure
you have gluten-free crackers and then
maybe another option it's just really an
amazing product I am proud to have been
the channel That the breath breathed
through in order to bring her onto
planet Earth and I'm just telling you
guys it's kind of funny because you know
I'll eat my own cheese and find myself
telling myself how good it is like even
still you know after all this time so
yeah it's cool uh Gabby and Rodrigo have
a company called House of now what time
is it rich I'm wearing it so they make
these watches that look like fancy you
know they're like fancy watches but all
it just says now on it there's no watch
hands or anything like that like it's
like what time is it it's now it's now
you know it's pretty cool yeah it's a
really really cool brand we're doing
some collaborations with them and you
know it's just a really uh fashionable
way it comes in a million colors it
comes in like gold Pink gold
white gold black silver
um it's really really beautiful
beautifully packaged and really cool
movement and message Behind the Music
the movement I've been thinking about
your startup Journey
um
lately uh in the context of what's gone
down with miyokos can we talk about that
a little bit sure so uh uh you know
you're in the middle of like trying to
complete an angel round of financing and
this is a process that uh you have
um been walking through quite gracefully
and what I mean by that is there have
been opportunities
over the course of the last I don't know
two years or whatever
to sit down with and entertain
investment from large Venture Capital
entities or like big money people who
place big bets on companies and we're in
a culture uh
in which you know fueled by kind of
Silicon Valley Hysteria
where we celebrate startup Founders who
raise gigantic amounts of cash right
it's like oh my God you know and
the the common story you know fast
forwarding years down the line is is
that often you know these big bets and
large Investments end up
uh you know sort of uh to the dismay of
the the founder like creating something
beyond what they intended right they end
up getting pushed out this happened to
Doug Evans it's kind of a
it's a you know it's a typical story
right like uh founder has a great idea
grows a company to a certain place takes
on a ton of money
uh a board of directors is compiled
these people you know need a return on
their investment they're on a timetable
they want an exit decisions are made
that often are contrary to the kind of
ethical underpinnings of the company's
origin uh and that's the nature of of
Commerce and and capitalism and and so
it goes and so this is a situation
that you had
quite a bit of conscious awareness
around and had the capacity to say no to
certain people who were interested in in
placing just such a big bet with you and
instead deciding upon
the
you know perhaps
uh more difficult or longer path of
only taking investment from people that
really resonated with you as like you
know basically like uh
uh you know people that are like on your
wavelength that share this vision and
being really conscious and careful about
that which means that this has taken a
little bit longer but also has been and
I think I'm speaking for you and saying
that has been much more gratifying like
even though there's a long way to go
like you feel really good about the
place that you're in right now and I
think that
when you look at miyoko and for people
who don't know miyoko
who who created and grew miyoko's uh
Creamery plant-based cheese and and
plant plant-based dairy products to a
certain place it's like it's a
ubiquitous brand right now it's
everywhere
you go you see it like she's done an
incredible job and really pioneered the
whole sector that you're in like she's
just the queen right but recently has
made headlines because she has been kind
of forced out of her own company and uh
and it's a big mess right now yeah yeah
how do you reflect on that like like an
incredible founder woman of color who
built like this amazing business you
know yeah well I mean it you know
it is the uh the condition of planet
Earth and what we have incarnated into
and every single woman listening to me
right now has their own stories of being
marginalized passed over uh you know
even abused even preyed upon even you
know so we can go down the whole rabbit
hole with that I mean that's just the
condition of this planet and it's by
Design when the feminine Consciousness
was ripped out of the spiritual lineage
of the planet thousands of years ago but
with regards to miyoko she is the um you
know the I would say uh Pioneer the the
founder of plant-based cheeses she has
been in it for many many many years I am
not a personal friend of hers I have met
her a couple times
um uh and uh and I am a fan of hers a
support of hers for what she did the
fact that I was able to sell my book
this cheese is nuts had everything to do
with the fact that she had published a
book before me
um so I have you know utmost respect for
her and for you know all the women
leaders all the all the mom gods that
are on the planet that know how to lead
innovate
um and curate and nurture and nourish
and grow you know amazing expressions of
Life all around us you know stemming
from the child then to whatever else
women do we all have 29 arms we're doing
it all
um so you know within the startup
culture this is the story that I hear
hear from many many Founders they say
um that you know
their their advice to me is take as
little money as you need and I know
currently you know a handful of them
that are going through similar similar
experiences as miyoko so it's like you
know they get a big investor they get a
big investment and then suddenly they
they're starting to lose their company
they're being questioned in the
integrity and their choices and
everything they're doing so I mean I
would say you know again I'm an artist I
am I am a devotional artist I think of
life and whatever medium that I'm
working in this entire expression of
plant-based Cheese came out of an
organic very authentic life experience
of us going through our process together
and you becoming vegan and me wanting to
nourish you and feed you and so for me
it's um
it's not a it's not a business idea it's
a natural evolution of life experience
and because I'm so seeped in devotion
when I create that these Foods these
shrimu wheels these flavors are infused
with spiritual consciousness it's a
frequency that is my prayer that when
whoever ingests it they remember who
they are they they get a little further
access into feeling connected
um and so for a while there I was being
sort of courted by some very big
companies that had taken other
plant-based Brands into these gigantic
valuations and I was trying to
understand it because I was like oh
there's a formula let me learn this and
then after I took all these meetings
which were like 60 meetings with almost
all men I saw four women and only no
front-facing women quite frankly like it
was shocking to me that the Venture
world is so void of women
um I mean no I in the end I did meet a
couple a couple women in the end that I
that I really really liked but and I
love men too like this isn't that
commentary but it's just the way that it
is
so I did finally get a message I heard a
message now I didn't hear the voice like
from God like Julie I like felt the
message like I was walking through our
living room and Something Told Me
kinesthetically in my body it said why
are you not applying the same amount of
spirituality artistry
and originality to the financial rays of
srimu as you did to the formulation and
branding of the product and it stopped
me mid-stride and I looked up at the sky
at whatever was communicating to me and
I said good question why am I not
because I didn't think I could because I
had compartmentalized that side and told
myself well you don't know business and
you don't understand raises and so you
can't do that so what I did is I said no
to one of those offers and then I went
to the crystal Warehouse you'll be happy
to hear and I bought a 13 specimens of
beautiful crystals
and I started lighting fire ceremonies
which is something I do I'm a fire
Priestess and and
uh I decided to call in my Cosmic Family
uh based on a 13 million valuation which
I gave myself
based on all the years that I've
developed hundreds of plant-based
recipes the fact that I developed uh you
know an actual product that I was
shipping to you know multiple
subscribers and and and that I had
proven this model with you know uh
positive margins already and many
successes that would validate me to
create that level of valuation there
were other companies that had 25 million
dollar valuations that had not shipped
one box of product or they were still in
in a development with different fake
meat things you know things like that
but I had actually been in the field
business not actually and and making
food you know creating food for for
years
so um
so what I did which is really annoying
to like old Paradigm business people
okay so I made it 13 million my
valuation because I'm a spiritual being
and uh having a seek a human experience
and 13 is my sacred number and it means
Unity so this intention of this
ceremonial Circle was to bring bring the
uh investors The Cosmic Family the
humanitarians into Unity around this
Mission and my Approach was I'm raising
3.3 because I kind of figured out like
that's a good amount but not too much
but now I'm even I'm starting to
reevaluate I don't think I am going to
raise that 3.3 I think I'm going to
knock it down so right now I'm in a
process of reassessing really how much I
need
um and I'm not going to take more than
that so what I told my Cosmic Family
that came into my field was that I'm not
promising you a 30 Roi but what I'm
promising you is a life experience that
will be a magic Carpet Ride that you
have never imagined and that we will
truly affect Humanity in the planet for
good for a higher vibration and that
we're going to have a blast in the Pro
in the process and that I mean it and
that I'm dedicated this to this with
every
ounce cell DNA strand of my being so I
am here for this completely
and so what this did is it brought this
beautiful collection of human beings who
are all amazing I don't hold back you
know the alien thing that I just said in
the first part of the podcast they've
all heard it and way more
um I'm I'm just completely transparent
with who I am let's be very I am not
posturing or holding anything back
um I talk to them about the the major
mission of srimu which is
um to fund the next evolution of the
temples in Domino Italy my beloved
Cosmic Family there I'm an initiate of
that Community they built temples to
Mankind in Secret inside a mountain that
are the true true Treasures true
devotional activators of Life on this
planet and they have plans for an 88
million dollar complex called the
parliament of the peoples which will
house the indigenous DNA of planet Earth
that is why I am in uh in the srimu
experience of course it will touch
millions of people along the way and at
the core of srimu is community so I am
interested in the touch human to human
touch and that is why I'm relocating my
production facility to Memphis Tennessee
I'm leaving tomorrow night and we're
having our first big team meeting this
space is almost ready for the production
side but we are moving into Memphis
Tennessee to Crosstown Concourse which
is a vertical community of the Arts of
music of uh healing of of community in
all ways
and it it is deeply deeply meaningful to
us so we are looking for brand
collaborations we are looking for
Meaningful Partnerships meaningful
co-creation it is all about the creative
process
um shrimu is a beauty brand the
plant-based artisanal cheese collection
is only the first product through this
lifestyle there will be you know
ayurvedic products Avianca oils many
many more food products
I'm working on a hair our product right
now my friend Brian who did The Branding
who is doing the cafe design we both
have some pretty
um Good Hair Care you and Brian together
should be you know like making
Billboards for you know hair products so
we're gonna so we're gonna do a hair
product and we're gonna shoot that which
is really great and you know this is all
about Community it's all about
connecting
um and you know like this board uh it's
about the celebration of diversity and
it is all are needed all are needed and
um it's a it's a super super expansive
uh time right now yeah well the
crosstown Concourse thing sounds really
cool I still haven't visited it yet but
um from what I gather and what you've
told me it's and I've seen lots of
pictures of it I mean it's it's hard to
wrap your head around the scale of this
place like you originally told me it was
an old Sears Roebuck building so in my
mind I'm thinking department store size
but in truth I think it was like a
factory it's the distribution facility
okay so it was like this yeah like it's
this massive massive complex it's like a
train station yeah that that was at one
time the center of you know a certain
you know sub-economy in Memphis for
Sears and Roebuck then went fallow and
fell into disrepair it didn't go I mean
I would say at some point I'd say they
just yeah I guess I would say they live
their lives they all lived these lives
and then died and it didn't come right
and so there was a period of time though
where it just was sitting there yes true
and uh it's been rejuvenated through
investment and now turned into this yeah
it turned into this incredibly dynamic
I mean it's not a ball it's a it's like
a a center it's like an in it's like its
own City it's a vertical Community
Theater yeah vertical yeah vertical uh
vertical Community there you go right
with like everything you could imagine
in it it's like including like recording
studios and airbnbs and is there a
school yeah and there's any thought High
School on the second floor there's a
YMCA Church Health teaching kitchens
artist in residency gigantic Photo Labs
like a Listening Library for vinyl right
incredible Listening Library
um performance theater like for a
thousand seats
um it's got uh you know restaurants
Global Cafe that is sabines which is
Refugee run
and then uh
Farm Burger they make a great burger
like not a fake veggie burger an actual
veggie burger there which is amazing and
we have this amazing red spiral
staircase that comes from the MoMA level
Museum gallery that they have and it
spills out right at my space and so um
we're just we're building this amazing
art installation where the cheese is
blessed and wrapped but it's going to
have like all these you know sound and
visuals
so people can watch exactly so you can
see the production it's going to be
like a storefront retail wine and cheese
Cafe experience yeah Cafe exactly with
Ready Made cheese boards grab and go or
you can come and sit in the cafe and
have wine or kombucha and enjoy a srimu
cheese board which is really really
exciting
what is the timeline on that being up
and running like you've begun the move
but yeah right so we're going to ship
our first month in Memphis in May so
we're moving we're going to be shipping
our Easter shipment
um and then we'll we're moving after
that so just so you guys know if you
order
um by uh March 12th then we'll ship on
the 14th of March and if you order by
the 2nd of April we'll ship you on the
4th of April so you'll get your shipment
for Easter Easter Passover we're going
to give you guys kind of give them a
code now
rrp20 and we're going to give free
shipping on any order over a hundred and
twenty seven dollars you can get all
different kinds of boxes Eternal
awakened devoted ritual or you can even
get a good a big commune box that has 12
Wheels reminding everyone these wheels
freeze perfectly
so you can freeze them and thaw them
within probably 40 minutes and they're
absolutely perfect there's no change in
the texture or the quality or anything
about it so anyway
um and then the other thing I wanted to
mention was we are looking for
um some amazing family members to join
us in the facility we're going to be
interviewing this week when we go there
but we're looking for high level
management kitchen management
also Cafe management so if anybody's
listening you can email us at do do life
at shreemu.com and someone will get back
to you on that but
um yeah it's um
it's very exciting it's very exciting
proud of you very excited I wish you
could come this week it's going to be
there's so many amazing people coming
and we're filming everything and so I
wanted to give a shout out to Bobby
Bailey uh who is a dear friend he and
his wife Aaron and he's going to be a
director on a film project that I'm
working on and
um yeah super exciting it's gonna be
super fun yeah
um
we had shifting gears a little bit we
had uh Scott Berman over here just for a
visit yesterday who's the uh guy who
created the sky cave Retreat Center the
brightness Retreat that's right we were
talking about that this morning yeah
yeah
like I'm considering like should I go
into the dark like Colin O'Brady did it
recently he's sending me videos and he's
like you gotta do it all in loved it and
uh uh and it's you know so I've been
thinking about it
um and I and and Scott was lovely like
he's clearly like the right person to be
doing this kind of work like it was
super interesting talking to him so I
came home
I was like yeah I'm at the darkness
Retreat guy and you're like
you already walk around in your own
self-created Darkness Retreat because I
was having fun I said like I've been
like the last two days I just haven't
felt great and I've been kind of off my
game you've been in the dark yeah you're
like you're in a Darkness Retreat now
did you tell no I was teasing you I just
said did you tell him that you have your
own dark cage and carry around with you
from time to time now we were talking
about it I mean it's cool it could be
really really cool
um you know I'm not going in anytime
soon I'm having too much fun out here so
probably gonna do it a lot of people
like it you know I did run into call in
actually uh at a very you ran into him
yeah almost randomly I think like right
after he came out of the cave I did yeah
that's right we were it was so funny
um Gabriella and uh Rodrigo invited me
skiing and so I I hopped over to Jackson
Hole and met them and they took me to
this party of some friends of theirs
Mariana and Yaniv and uh they were like
SRI you know there are a lot of people
are a lot younger than we are you know
so you know we'll just roll in and then
I mean I'm older than they are but
they're like you know we're rolling and
roll out so we go in and I just find a
comfy place like on some you know fur
throw on the on the fireplace hearth and
I'm sitting in Lotus and you know
Rodrigo said he's like oh look at trees
over there we're gonna have to leave in
like you know a few minutes like not
stay too long whatever and then the DJs
were really amazing and then all of a
sudden I got up and I started dancing
cut to like three hours later I'm just
in the middle of the Dance Floor Just
and and they were laughing so hard so
they we were getting ready to leave
finally after this three-hour dance
thing and I went over to get my my phone
and it was on the Hearth and this guy
with these ridiculous round kind of
plastic glasses and and like some funky
sweatshirt was like standing right there
and then he says to me what's your name
or no he says nice hat right and then it
turned out it was Colin and we were just
cracking up because we ran into each
other so then we we had a nice share but
did he reflect back to you anything yeah
he was like it was insane it was crazy
it got to get rich in there it was
really incredible
yeah cool so it was sweet well
um I'm ready to round this out but I
think it would be good if you could you
know share a practice or uh you know
something to reflect upon yeah as we
culminate this experience
um I mean the one thing that has been
sort of up for me and that you know I
have people reach out to me
a lot about death
and I've had a lot of people
um telling me like that they heard an
episode on death that I did I don't even
know where
um but they said that it you know really
really helped them or really shifted
their experience
and I just want to remind people that
thoughts are things and that we are
eternal life forms
and the best way that we can serve our
fellow Humanity our animals
um and our loved ones who choose their
sacred exit during these times or even
if they have already chosen their sacred
exit and you felt like you couldn't be
there for you for them or you didn't
know what to do or it was also
mechanical that you couldn't really
um couldn't really participate I just
want to remind you that time does not
exist Beyond this Dimension and so where
your loved ones are you can still do a
ceremony you can still offer them a
prayer a song a sentiment and remember
that it's like they're getting ready
they're in a bird suit and they're
getting ready to jump off a mountain
and they're afraid of heights
and so your grief
your sadness
and your inability to let them go
is like lead weights around them
and so yes there is a time to grieve
there is a time to cry there is a time
to to go through those processes but
remember the greatest thing you can do
is to imagine that there is a iridescent
blue cord
and imagine them in whatever form you
see them in and start at below their
feet and start to imagine that you weave
this cocoon
start weaving this blue cocoon all
around them and take your time and
breathe and tell them
thank you I love you I trust you I
believe in you and I know we will see
each other again
and
go ahead and do it all the way over your
loved ones and remember that blue light
is the calming light
and
remember that if you are excessively
grieving or unable to accept what is or
have not really explored death and you
are really fearing your own death which
is what's making you
um you know sort of stuck in a way or so
upset
um just remember that you can send them
these prayers in this way and you can do
it repeatedly you can do it whenever
you're missing them
and then I would offer that there is an
opportunity for communication that is
beyond anything that we ever imagined
and so in your mind develop a sign with
that being that has left whether it's a
butterfly or whether it's a golden coin
whatever it is
and say that in your inner intention
and ask for the communication
and then wait and see how they
communicate to you and how you see that
sign or that sign appears when they are
near many many people have this
experience but I'm just reminding many
of us have had to say goodbye to people
and it is a very tender very raw time
for many of us and so
um I just want to invite people to maybe
close their eyes for a second if that
feels okay with you not if you're
driving
and let's just
um
collect our breath together let's start
to sink our breath up
and so bring your awareness to your
breath
and take some deep inhales long deep
fluid inhales
pausing at the top of that inhale for
just a moment
and then let's take another Collective
exhale together
and just releasing that down
and allow it to completely empty out
maybe draw your belly slightly to your
spine
and just take that pause again
and then let's take another breath
together as we inhale through the nose
long deep fluid free breath
and as you get to the top let's stop
for just a moment fall into that Gap
and then let's exhale together
collectively
exhaling all the breath out Let It Be
Free
and at the bottom maybe you pull your
belly gently into your spine emptying
out
and let's pause again
and again let's take another breath
through the nose
a long deep fluid inhale
drawing the breath up
pausing at the top
and then exhale
letting the breath release down
as you continue to breathe like that I'm
just going to open the field
in sacred service to the law of one
and as we ignite as a community as a
Humanity
across all timelines all realities all
dimensions and the void
we ask command and intend for the
highest exchange according to the Future
Wills of our God selves embodied
beloved teams from the Multiverse please
comfort our Humanity who are suffering
now
please ignite Your Grace your
nourishment your guidance your
companionship around them
where there is suffering
let our Humanity feel our presence
that united we are mighty
we are sovereign
and we are omniscient
so beloveds
feel this in your heart space the place
where you first heal this is the port
the first field the portal the inkling
Into the Heart
yeah and returned there after this
podcast
through this inner chamber of the heart
intelligence
and let's find each other
waiting there
we're not going without you
remember who you are
and so it is
beautiful
thank you that's all I got
well I'm sure there's another podcast in
our future you can save it until then
thanks for having me on yeah thank you
love you babe
[Music]